[Music]
thank you for for coming to my
presentation the topic of my talk is
talk with virtual environments and
dependency management in Python so as
you can see it's more Python general
presentation it's focused on tools that
you can use to first of all manage
virtual environments and Python Python
installations and the second of all how
to how to manage a dependency
dependencies of your project of your
Python project my name is Patricia chic
and it's stopped working for for a
second okay so what I do on my day to
day job I'm a Python and blockchain
developer in pragmatic coders and in
addition to that I'm also one of the
organizers of crack of Python user group
called Peconic and what I will be
talking about is I want to answer two
questions how you can manage multiple
Python verses on your own your computer
how to manage virtual environments and
what they are useful for and how you can
manage project dependencies so you can
achieve reputable reputable environments
I believe that's not working as it
should so let's
sorry sorry for that but I believe that
internet is not working properly
okay sorry for the technical problems so
I would like to answer three questions
how to manage multiple Python versions
how to manage virtual environments and
how to manage project dependencies and
for starters probably since you're using
Python a lot of you already know pip I
just wanted to mention that it's a
package installer that is recommended by
python packaging authority it's
distributed with with Python from
versions two point seven point nine and
three point four and above and by
default it uses packages installed from
pi PI the torque you can go to the to
that side and search for the packages
here and how to use pip it's actually
quite straightforward
you have the comment available pip
install for installing packages you can
also specify the minimal version like in
the second example you can specify the
exact version of the package that you
want to use and you can also use
requirements list that takes the format
file for installing multiple
dependencies at once with the - or flag
for an instant Inc we have we have
people install package comments to two
other useful comments are people east
and P priests both of those are used for
listing installed packages there is a
small difference between them people is
to list all the all the packages that
are installed it includes also pip since
it's also a Python package it also
includes setup tools for example but it
has a really useful flag which is - -
outdated and with that flag you can
check for outdated packages in your
environment with people freeze you can
you can produce a list of all installed
packages excluding people setup tools
and you can use it to quickly produce
the requirements that take step
so let's try to answer the first
question which is how to manage multiple
Python versions and for that we have the
tool called PI F so if you're for
example working on multiple projects
with multiple Python versions you can
use that in addition to traditional C
Python you can also install other
interpreters for example type I or J
Python or ironpython if you're familiar
with node.js or Ruby ecosystem it's
really similar to tools like nvm and our
VM what what might be disqualifying for
some of you it's not working on Windows
I looked but failed to found the working
solution for Windows but I will also
mention other other tool that is able to
manage Python versions on Windows and
how it works it works in a little bit of
magical way so what it does it inserts
pie in Jim's directory at the beginning
of your search path so when when when
executed executable is search for it it
always will find a shim with with
executable and the shim is a small small
file small small program that that
passes the comment to the correct pylons
so for example if you want to invoke the
common pip the path will be searched for
for the executable named pip it will
find the pine fishing with named pip and
it will pass it to the correct correct
Python version and see how the how the
correct version is chosen first it
checks for the environment variable
called pi in version we can set that
environment with the common pi in shell
if that's not found it checks if if a
file that python version exists in
current directory you can use the common
piles local for that for for creating
that file you can also create that file
by hand if you if you'd like
if that's not found it tries to find the
Python version file in the parent
directory it searches up to the root of
your file system and if that's not found
it uses the default which is start in
your home directory that PI ended slash
version file and you can use the comment
pile of global to actually set that mmm
I also want to mention the PI in update
plugin it only does one thing it
provides the ability to actually
actually actually update your PI
installation
it not only updates PI in but also all
plugins so basically what it does it
updates available Python versions so if
you're if you're using PI n F and you're
not updating it for half a year then you
will be missing the the latest releases
of Python or other distribution
distributions of Python for example J
Python and how to use it as I said we
can install different versions of Python
interpreter with it for example you can
you can install Python three point six
point two what's interesting it it can
also install for example anaconda
probably some of you are using anaconda
it's it also has has it available for
listing all available Python
interpreters you have common Pi
inversions and for uninstalling you just
type Python install with with the proper
name or proper version and as I
mentioned before you have the common PI
in shelf Pi in shell PI in local and
final global for setting current current
Python interpreter and you can check
which one is used with with the PI
inversion command so mmm so now that we
know how we can manage multiple Python
versions we can move on to two virtual
environments so
it's a different different type of
separation on pylons level we're
separating different versions of Python
on our system with virtual environments
we're actually separating environments
in in this a with the same version of
Python so what we get is isolated and
independent environments so we can be
sure that we can use for example library
in two different versions if you want to
test it or if you want if you want to be
sure that we won't break our Python our
system Python installation and yeah it
basically allows testing and using
third-party libraries without without
worries and to isolate your project from
the other part of the system and since
it's a very popular in in Python
community it became a part of the
standard library
starting from Python 3.3 and how
virtualenv works there's also a little
bit of a little bit of magic to it first
of all there are two parts for using it
we're using the activate command and
essentially what it does it just inserts
path to the binary of Python at the
beginning of path so the proper Python
will be used when you're trying to
invoke it for example from the command
line and the second part how it actually
how it actually resolves modules that
are installed Python uses is something
called since that path you can import
this module and check what's what's in
there it contains the list of search
paths for four modules during imports
and to this since that path is populated
by file call side dot pi so what what
the guys from virtual and did is to
modify that side that PI so it will
point and so it will populate this that
path with with paths to the virtual
environment and to not to replicate the
standard library they also included the
origin takes down which also includes
standard library from the
Python installation from which the
virtual and which Rollins was created
and say a little different approach was
used by hey guys that implemented it in
standard library they actually used the
file called pythons CFG and if there is
a there is this file available then the
Python interpreter knows that is running
in the in the virtual environment so it
can create two prefixes since that
prefix which is a prefix pointing to the
virtual and installation and this is
that base tree fixed which is pointing
to the original one so it can include
standard library from the from the
original one and in both cases the
packages are installed two paths to end
slash sleep slash Python with number
version and first aid packages you can
inspect them here and a you can you can
see how the Python CFG file looks home
just points to the allocation of the
Python binary from which the virtual was
created and the include system side
packages we can set it to true if you
want if you want to use the packages
installed on them on the system Python
and also also the version so how we can
use it it's quite straightforward
if we run Python to a lower than three
point three we need to install it for
example with Pip and after installing it
we have the comments virtual and
available to us we just we just say we
want to create our virtual ins with
Python 3.3 and higher we have two
options
one is already duplicated so I'm not
recommending to use it but it's
available so it's good to know it's
called pythons and we just point to the
point path where we want it to be
created but the recommended option is to
use a Python
M VNV and provide the path and we can
activate it with with sourcing the
activate a file or with after that we
can just type deactivate a comments to
to deactivate the virtual and
so but to simplify things there is a
plugin which is called pi and virtual EV
which integrates virtual lengths with
with the pi in so we can create virtual
ins from the from the pi and it also has
supports for managing counter
environments that they will be
mentioning in a bit and it works with
the virtual and installed from pip as
well as the one that is a part of the
standard library the comments to use it
are quite straightforward as well we
just type PI in virtual and we can
provide the version and the name of the
virtual and if we if we omit the version
it will use the currently used one with
PI in virtual else we can list all of
all of existing humphs and for working
we also have activate and deactivate
what we need to use a pine
we need to use PI in version with PI and
activate and deactivate and for removing
we have PI individual and - delete
comments so other tool that combines
that combines all of those so
environments managing Python versions
and installing packages is condom what's
important is it's multi-platform so you
can use it on Windows unlike the the PI
in that I mentioned before
it also supports pip for instant Inc
packages inside environments and what's
really important about Conda is that it
instance binary packages so there is no
need to compile and there is no problems
with installation like for example
you're missing compile compiler and you
have problem problems with it and thanks
to the fact that it installs binary
packages it's also possible to install
packages that are written in other
languages for example it treats peyten
as every other package so you can also
install for example packages from
Fortran or binaries from C and comes
with Anna
in Minicon the distributions and how how
we can create environments with it we
have the common counter create we can
provide the name we can provide the list
of packages that you want to install in
our environment for example cars we can
also specify the Python version we can
also create a clone of existing
environment with with the - - clone dr.
strong flag - our command for listing
environments we have Condor info there -
shelves or the newer version which is
called an list and for working with them
we have similar commands as for virtual
and PI individuals a activate and
deactivate you need to prepend the
source if you're on Mac OS or or Linux
and for removing we have counter remove
we provide the name of the environment
and say add the flag - - all so to
remove the the whole environment and
installing packages is similar to pip
however as you can see you only spare is
only one equality equal sign between
name of the package and the version and
you can also by default it installs in
currently activated environment if you
but you also can provide a name
explicitly so you can be sure that it's
installed in the proper proper one and
for uninstalling you have the counter
remove and similar to installing you you
can also remove from the specified
environment and for for inspecting
installed packages we have the counter
list comment and about dependency
management so what can we get from
dependency management so for example you
start the project you you just have a
simple script your pip installing
everything in your virtual environment
but later you for example you want to
share it through with someone you want
to share it if colleague a you put your
push it to github
other person clones it and tries to run
it and it doesn't work because it's
missing libraries so the first the first
thing that we get from dependency
management is that we have a list of
external libraries that our project
actually needs to run it's very often in
a simple form of the requirements that
takes the file we can go further with
that and we can provide a few
requirements that takes the files so we
can provide for example logical
separation of dependencies for example
we can create a separate list for for
testing for development environment and
for production environment we can also
provide a simpler list for humans to
read and also we can provide a list for
machines which have all dependencies
with specified versions locked so we are
able to actually create so we are
actually create a Bidoof environments
that are exactly the same as on our
machine so we didn't have a problem that
it's working on my computer but if you
if you do it right then it's really easy
to reproduce on on production machine or
other user computer so to start with it
we have the simple tool which is called
paper eggs it only does one thing a it
inspects your whole project for for
imports and it creates a requirement
that takes the file with all the
packages that you actually imported in
your inner file that is that has a big
advantage over the simple Petrie's
redirect to a requirements that takes
them because you might for you maybe
forgot that you installed other other
packages for example you installed
ipython or something else and you don't
need you don't need it to end up here so
it will just include the packages that
your project is actually using important
it only it only includes those packages
that are imported in your project so the
dependencies of those packages are not
included here but if you if you also
want to include them which is a really
good idea a not so good idea of
rewriting libraries because
users of your libraries may have problem
but if you're creating an application or
some script then it's good idea to pin
all your dependencies so provide all
specific versions not only for
dependency that your project uses but
also a packages needed but by dada by
those dependencies and for that we can
use call tool called peep-toes which is
which have two commands it's essentially
two tools it's big compiled and people
sync and it has a notion of having two
separate lists one is for humans to read
and one is only for machines which which
is not supposed to be edited by by human
and how it works for example we have a
simple project that uses two packages
called for example frost and request
those are two of the most common and
popular packages in the Python
ecosystem and we save it in the
requirements that in file and with PIP
compile we can produce our pinned
requirements that takes the file which
will be a list of dependencies for
machines the first one is just for
humans just simple top-level
dependencies and at the end after the
PIP compile as we can see we have the
list is quite bigger all all packages
have specified versions and in addition
to flask and request you can see that
there is more we can inspect in the
comments created by PI compile which
package was installed like what was the
source for this package why was it
installed for example we can see that
ginger too was installed because of
flask and we can also use it to upgrade
later specific packages because the
requirements that takes that is not
supposed to be edited by human so if you
want to update it you again people
compile the requirements that invert a
file we can also use - - to generate
hashes flag which will in addition to
pinning your versions of dependency
in addition we'll also create hashes for
the packages so if someone is tampering
with the package on the pipe eye for
example and there is a the the version
number is the same but the package is
different the harshest won't much and it
won't be installed and to to sync a
current environment with with
requirements that takes the file you can
use the comment called pip sync it will
uninstall on all packages that are not
specified in the requirements that takes
that and is to install all needed so you
have a clean environment with only a
with only packages that actually your
application needs and I also wanted to
mention a new standard that is coming
right now is only right now it's only
experimental but there is a
specification called pip file which is
called requirements that takes that 2.0
is the proposition of a new standard and
this project is supported by pi PI it's
supposed to replace the requirements
that takes - it's not only one file but
but two files which will be similar to
the example from peep-toes we will have
P 5 and P frylock when with pip pip file
being like the list for humans which
will only contains top level
dependencies and the PIP 5 lakh will
contains all pinned dependencies with
hashes and and the source from which the
packages should be installed and they
use the tamil syntax instead of just
simple requirements that takes the
format and that's an example of a simple
pip file what's neat about it is that it
contains additional section called def
packages which is a good place to keep
packages that they're not needed on
production servers so for example PI
test for testing or ipython for playing
with with know with with with the code
or something like that so that's cool
that we have one one one file Bo because
if you want to use it with a pip compile
we need to have a separate for example
- requirements that in file for that we
also have the Python version in the
source folder for the packages and I
just wanted to show the p5 lock it's not
the whole whole file because it's much
bigger but as you can see it contains at
the at the end of the of the slide there
is one of the packages we have the pin
version we have the hashes and there is
only one project right now that actually
uses this new format which is called pip
and it's it's recommended to use by
python packaging Kaltura team so I
believe that in the coming future the P
file format will be much more common and
much more widespread what it is is
essentially a mixture of pip pip file
and virtual and so a little bit similar
to kondeh what it does it automatically
creates virtual honest for you so you
don't need to worry if you install
something it will create a virtual and
for you if you if it doesn't exist yet
it automatically also adds and removes
dependencies from pip file during
installation and installation if you're
using the pip tools you need to manually
add everything to your a requirement
that in file but with but with people it
will if your pip and install something
it will automatically update your pip
file and it also created the pip file
log file it can use it installed
dependencies from that file the pic
frylock also I didn't mention it's not
supposed to be edited by human similar
to the requirements that takes that from
the previous example and it by default
uses hashes for packages verification
and to manage python versions it
recently added integration with pi f so
you can have everything by using Pippins
and Pyun if you have management of
versions management of your dependencies
and virtual environments and how to use
it you can manually create a new project
with specifying python version if you
don't do that during people installed if
the project doesn't exist if your
virtual doesn't exist it will be created
if you pip and install request it will
be
to the P file if you add the flag -
there's def it will be added to the def
packages in pip file and uninstalling an
instance the packages the package and
also removes it from from the PIP file
and for installing all dependencies we
we have the people in stock comment it
will install all dependencies from your
log file excluding the dev packages but
if we add the - there's a flag it will
install all the dependencies and for
spawning a shell with virtual and we
have people shell comment it also has a
few additional features one of them is
PIP and graph which is useful for
actually looking how the dependency
graph or our project looks like we have
also people check which checks for
security security vulnerabilities of our
installed packages and we can also
manually generate in the new log file so
it will update the versions from with
the Pippins lock comment so the summary
if you for instance packages you have
people Conda and people a pip and fuses
pip underneath for managing Python
installation you have two options Conda
and PI F or you can manage them yourself
for environments we have virtual length
by in virtual ins and Conda or people
and for managing dependencies peoples
and people are the most common one and
my recommendation would be to use Pippen
with PI n F you have everything with
that or if for some reason you want to
you want to be sure that your other
binary packages are working then you can
go with Conda I have much more
experience with people and it's working
a really great and that's my
recommendation for for using and thank
you
thank you
just a short question why don't you
recommend working with Conda because for
me it makes life much more easier
because it takes care also about the
binary stuff and for example with with
people sometimes you need to install
some system dependencies and it's it's a
pain so why not forget about all these
mmm other tools and just use Conda
actually Conda is not officially
supported by Python Packaging authority
or Python Software Foundation in any way
so that's why I'm recommending other
tools that are recommended and it will
be honest I believe Conda is only
popular in data science communities and
machine learning it's not really used
outside of that thank you
you